[Music]
make sure your children what happens if
I use your rayban make sure you don't
start missing it as you get you're
coming this way hey whitey keep it real
watch your ranging yet okay okay some
things to know he has a linear line okay
my job talk to you make him miss by a
mile my Thomas make him barely miss so
he goes
[Music]
if you watch different right I have a
tiny win there's in your energy
whoo hey let's see that
now early
keep posture watch your hunch
get your arms up so that it's not
getting stabbed in the back
my arms were up too early now you're not
fighting him you are in a stance
Virginia and okay is not counting coup
or tagging sharks so you're supposed to
penetrate the target with that weapon
you are fighting her
put your hands up out of the way you
find her
you have to penetrate their weapon not
penetration enough James
so if you would bend your knees more on
the ski you would be able to travel
further instead of reserving your glute
energy for who knows what you could just
train harder the drill was slow just
like rode and demonstrated it slow I'm
not going to say it again you will all
slow down because you obviously don't
know who it is
fight him
drill ships
[Music]
and this charge you but you have he'll
wait James
as you have that sunken chest
he's straight so you pick your target
and then you stay on that line you don't
track them cuz they're going slow pick
your target and you hit that same target
that's too low
don't move your feet you're on your
heels that's music here
you go forward with them
so then I have my beanie on so I can I
might have to do that physically I will
always do it internally though and now
to make that part of my eating meals
okay
so again as he comes in I'm not going
[Music]
but I want to go I needed to go forward
today make it a go back so I
you
[Music]
that's it so you brought him in more the
last tier you are
when it's time to DVD me that's a strike
that's a strike
training
[Music]
you haven't either have no injury or
like a two to four inch TV you okay both
unacceptable right I am yen but now I'm
wrong okay
you have I have people who won't go yen
at all and then I have people's like
once onion I don't think I'm gonna stay
here okay it's gonna there's a
sweet spots in the head so I don't want
to I'm not pushing her back if she comes
in sweet spot to the kid okay coming in
perfect spot here we go so there's the
same time woo you can hear her John
clothes on and this is not about seafoam
we can be right you may see her violence
is beating so what I think this other
thing that's a strike it's not it's a
back strikes
but there's a sweet spot where you can
allow this Center to come forward keep
their head back watch on mascara on her
compared run he is actually purse okay
you
you're not just touching the face did
you have a magic hand give you arm
extended and hit the sweet spot already
in posture
already is hot
there's no hip rotation on the stripe
the hip rotation was on the deviation at
full speed you won't have be able to
[Music]
but that's not the that's not the speech
someone has to go crash but it gets
traveling that speed
you have to hit imposture
this triangular to the jawline same
thing is your front foot closer to the
line or further from the line let's go
and you're doing it before so you're
missing his face hold the joke
we'd rather her not have it and get up
and use it again
[Music]
okay train slow I gotta obey the same
physics okay
context training is good to you slow
motion but I can't go like this go watch
my house where my hands going and then
I'll find the weapon
there's the driveway if you have a void
it already hooks where you wore don't
train yourself to grab it yet okay let's
go
you
[Music]
DiBiase triangular vase so wait why your
foot front foot is further from the line
of attack is because you're trying to
create about a foot angle deviation you
don't need a foot angle deviation the Jo
is only one inch wide when you add my
rotation my front foot should be about
an inch off the initial line of attack
then my back foot will have no problem
getting further away from that and I
will have a triangular base which will
give me a wedge shape which will help
with the displacement of their balance
let's go each rep get closer to the Jo
each rep bring them in each rep make
contact with longer each rep makes that
Devi DiBiase
look at your feet look at your foot
you're supposed to make contact in
position already you missed again you're
looking down this is not a triangle look
at your feet
we do catch the Jo at the end
[Music]